before we give those scary stories I
want to talk about the Walk of Fame
ceremony watching you with your star
waving the Mexican flag I mean what
what's that moment feel like for you
it's very much like a moment in which
what I felt
going through the stars of people I
admired and in storytelling you know
weird people mostly or people that came
from my country it inspired me and I was
hoping to live a little bit of that
there a lot of del rey was there to
present to you and I know you guys
collaborated on this film she had a song
but how did you guys become besties well
I I've admired her work for a while let
me go see him she has a very unique
quality to evoke images with her songs
and her voice and her music and I when
when we thought about somebody covering
the season of the witch I immediately
said I know I know the person that
should and would because she loves
Donovan and she loves that era of music
you know and it's such a race she has a
new album coming out would you ever like
direct her musically I would yes I would
I mean I'm terrible at those assignments
I've never done commercials or videos
because I take so long I mean the
fastest I've shot movie is 20 20 days
how's the fastest I don't know if I
would survive or she would want me
alright because music videos they just
want like a people of their yeah now you
guys met how all great partnerships Matt
I read twitter.com
yeah how did you guys meet IDM yeah I
was tweeting around his movie yes yes no
he you know he followed me so I followed
him and I good the ampion and I I was
tweeting about the other see of Jane Doe
which is a movie by right there that I
loved is so scary what's oil and mmm and
and I thought this is a guy I mean
Andrew hunter his previous movie
was so unique and so brilliant so I
wanted to be pals with a guy you know
well a lot of people grew up with scary
stories to tell in the dark that the
books how did you pick which stories you
wanted to use in the movie I know
obviously that was your process with the
writers but I mean it's so within an
American Idol ya know it sort of when
who likes which one and we came back to
nine or ten of the stories everybody
wanted to see and then we said which
ones suit the characters the prom queen
and yet the red spot the guy that is
very picky eater can get the big cow and
so on and so forth you know there's so
many more stories that weren't explored
and it kind of feels like there's room
for more or like what would you guys
like to see next would there be more
movies sequels or maybe like a TV show
if the movie connects I think we we
agree that we would like to collaborate
again and and there is there's over a
hundred stories left in the books so
absolutely you guys are a fan of each
other's but what about your
collaboration do you think made it work
so well well I admire him sincerely and
respect him sincerely and for me that's
producing I'm gonna finally almost since
films since I went to film school so
it's been amazing to be able to learn
from him through the process of honing
in this film it's just been a master
class for me for a year now what's your
favorite gear Melville I mean all this
shape of water I mean I think that is
that the culmination of all the things
that he loves in his movies that my
favorite do people are very attached to
your shape of water but also your comic
book movies and I feel like every time
people talk about comic book movies your
name comes up on the list of like dream
directors yeah what is that something
you would want to do again another comic
book I don't think so I wanted to learn
Justice League dark and
that's really very very very much but it
didn't happen but other than that I when
I was doing the Hellboy movies or blade
you know they were counter to what
everything being was being done and so
it was fun to break the rules there you
know and I try not to do them the way
they would have been done by anyone else
I think that just the thing that was
attractive because of that because
they're all monsters but I was never a
superhero now I liked monsters
yeah what happened with Justice League
dark oh you have an hour I have two
minutes long story okay I also think
that people are always going to wonder
what the ending of the Hellboy trilogy
would have been oh that that maybe if
you ever see me over somewhere and we
have dine on I'll tell you the story
yeah
do you think that like mass audiences
will ever know know that's Doug's I mean
both Ron and I are now bastard yeah okay
fair enough but you're also doing a lot
of people are talking about night Barry
Allen right now because that cast is
insane very exciting but also Pinocchio
yes that seems like one cuz you said you
like to do things that are like kind of
counterculture a lot of people know that
story what what about this Pinocchio is
all believe me del Toro this is somebody
said oh there's another Pinocchio and
there's another one I said no no no
Pinocchio will be yeah like this one is
it this is stop-motion yeah it's
basically a very very personal movie
it's a reflection about what it is to be
human
you know and it has some elements that
come directly from the book and some
others that have never been in the book
or the story but I think it's essential
to to Pinocchio to understand like
Frankenstein what the world is about
you
[Music]